everybody welcome to the r studio
enterprise community meetup
i'm rachel dempsey i'm calling in from
boston today
i'll be your host for today's meetup
this is my first time trying out youtube
live so i'm joined by my colleague tom
tom mock hanging out behind the scenes
as well so thank you so much tom
if you've just joined now feel free to
introduce yourselves through the chat
window and say hello maybe put in where
you're calling in from
for today's meetup we are joined by paul
chang senior data and applied scientist
at microsoft
so paul is going to share their data
science workflow using r our studio
connect and azure for capacity planning
of microsoft data centers
and so after paul's presentation we'll
have lots of time for q a as well so you
can put your questions in the youtube
chat
or you can use the slido link as well
for anonymous questions
we'll share that in the chat it's also
in the youtube video details
but that slido link is just
rstd.io
meetup questions
for anyone who's joining for the first
time
welcome to our studio enterprise
community meetup
this is a friendly and open meetup
environment for teams to share the work
they're doing within their organizations
teach lessons learn network with each
other and really just allow us all to
learn from each other
so while we usually meet on zoom we
wanted to give youtube live a try here
thank you all so much for making this a
welcoming community
we really want to create a space where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone so just want to
reiterate that we love to hear from
everyone no matter your level of
experience or industry that you're in as
well
and so we'll share a few
links in the video details as well if
you ever have suggestions or general
feedback please let us know
but with that thank you all so much for
joining us and i would love to turn it
over to our speaker for today's meetup
paul chang
hey paul
hey great uh thanks rachel thanks tom
and thanks everybody for uh joining in
uh in this presentation
um so
uh so yesterday i will be talking about
capacity planning for
azure data centers uh and uh this is a
joint work with uh you know our
fantastic team uh sarah ivy
yayoon ritty sajay and serge
uh but this is also joint work with our
former uh team members as well so ahmed
who's at airbnb
and also jingyi and yantau who
have moved on to different roles in
microsoft
okay so
the the agenda for this presentation so
i will
describe the capacity planning process
for azure data centers
i'll then describe how we use our studio
connect
to generate these capacity plans
um the value that we get from our studio
connect
and then i'll do a
demo
uh involving a simplified version
of a shiny dashboard
that we built
okay so um
before we get into the the planning
process uh let's get to know azure a
little bit
uh so azure is microsoft's cloud
platform
we have 200 products and cloud services
we serve over a billion
customers
worldwide
20 million
companies are on azure
and we're in uh 60
plus regions around the world
uh we have over 90 regulatory compliance
offerings
the most of any cloud provider
95 percent of fortune 500 companies are
in azure
uh and um
microsoft spends a billion dollars in
cyber security every year so microsoft
is very very passionate about
data security data privacy
now
in order to
enable these cloud services
we have built a global infrastructure
that consists of 165 000 miles of fiber
optic cable
over 200 data centers
and a lot of land
a lot of land
um
key features of our azure data centers
um high availability
uh low latency so um super important for
gamers right
uh scalability
uh and um you know azure
by using azure we
uh ensure that our customers have access
to the latest cloud technologies
uh your data is safe and secure
right so
um if you
architect uh your your workload in a
certain way
uh where your workload consists of
multiple azure services
uh those azure services can
communicate with one another over the
microsoft network so that the ip traffic
never enters the public internet and so
your data stays safe
and secure
okay so now let's uh let's talk about
capacity planning a little bit
so we are a group of economists data
scientists
and we work with this fantastic group of
program managers to produce the
long-range capacity plan for
azure data centers
now some some characteristics of our
plan so we do look at the one two seven
year
time horizon
uh and the data center build out process
is characterized by
somewhat long lead times
so typically
you know roughly around the two-year
mark but in certain instances that lead
time could be a lot longer
than uh than two years
uh we invest billions of dollars in our
data centers and our global
infrastructure
and our capacity plan is for the 60-plus
regions uh that we are in right now
uh and with the hope of uh
expanding into a lot more regions in the
coming years
okay in terms of uh our workflow uh
summary
uh these are roughly the main entities
that we interact with so so know that
this diagram is not necessarily
reflective of
our internal organizational structure
but i think this captures the salient
features
of our workflow
so we're capacity planning in the center
there
we ingest data from hardware and region
design
we ingest demand from various partners
to generate
our demand forecast models and our
capacity plans
we
also collaborate closely with finance
to iterate on the capacity plans
and we also collaborate with our supply
team closely as well
so we give demand signals to our supply
team they in turn do the hard work of
figuring out
where the supply is
where the you know most cost effective
supply is and they give that information
back to us which in turn
affects or influences where we shape
demand
okay so now let's double click on a
demand bucket first
so
here are some main categories of demand
inputs that we consider there's this
bucket that we call organic data so it
consists of economic data and historical
azure revenue
that we use to feed into our econometric
and data science
models
on top of that we do
consider capacity requests from various
microsoft engineering groups
being office 365 xbox
as well we also consider
uh capacity requests from our large
customers so we actually have a large
team of people who talk with governments
and
large enterprises you know fortune 500
companies and
uh you know these these customers when
they onboard onto azure or they make a
new capacity request
those capacity asks are actually pretty
large usually
and so those those type of large
capacity requests are not necessarily
forecastable
by the
historical
data
so for that reason we need really need
to consider
demand from large customers
as a separate bucket
okay in terms of hardware and region
design
so
azure services right so various azure
services actually depend on core
azure services
uh some azure services have special
server requirements special hardware
requirements so we need to take account
of those
considerations uh the hardware roadmap
that's another a big input for us um so
uh yeah i don't know if moore's law is
still valid or not um but
i think i think it is still our
uh
our thinking that as time goes on cpus
should become more powerful and uh
energy efficient uh and so if if cpus
and gpus they get better and better the
thinking is perhaps
we might need fewer servers and maybe
even fewer buildings to serve the same
demand
supply so we build data centers we lease
data centers
and i said as i said before we want to
know where the supply is around the
world
okay so
so we ingest all that information from
our partners
to
produce the capacity plan
these are
roughly you know four of the
main pillars that support our work
that allow us to produce the
capacity plan
so the first is revenue forecasts
so
uh we have a revenue forecast model
that employs a couple of well understood
models that we stitched together
including a
model on technology diffusion
inspired by diego coleman we have a
hierarchical time series model
that allows us to
distribute a worldwide revenue forecast
down to the geo and region level
we have a gravity model of trade
the hardware roadmap is another big
pillar
that our team
works on so
uh i mean microsoft does have an
internal
uh hardware roadmap but you know
it's not necessarily written in stone
right so they're you know all sorts of
things could pop up and
that plan may need to be changed from
time to time so so we do want to
actually forecast
uh
that hardware roadmap as well to the
extent that we can
capacity principles are also important
right so we need to account for the
discrete sizes of various data centers
due to their design
and we also need to build in safety
stock to
for supply lead time
and volatility on both the supply and
demand sides
and the fourth is demand shaping
which i'll talk more about
in the demo a demo uh later in this
presentation
okay so so that hopefully gives people a
good
overview of you know what we do what's
our process
uh so to summarize
the demand info we use for our
models comes from historical revenue
and sales data
as well as capacity requests
from large customers and microsoft
engineering groups
we need to account for hardware and
region design requirements
including special or premium hardware
needed for various microsoft engineering
groups
supply so so we need to be aware of the
places where we have plenty of supply
and where we don't
in certain cases we want to lease data
centers because of the lower lead time
and in other cases we want to build data
centers to have more control
and
maybe uh lower costs
and in all we do we want to be
uh fiscally responsible
so
that's that's uh very important
okay so
[Music]
for our team what are the
top considerations for our team
for doing this
capacity planning
i think the
um
close to the top one
is accuracy
right um
so like like many other data science
teams uh we care very much about
accuracy
uh it's it's how we build credibility
super important that our models are
accurate
um so but that's but that's not the only
consideration
uh that we need in order for our team to
be successful
right so
i think uh data science teams and models
they they tend to over index on accuracy
uh but in order to
make our models a success
we need other factors as well
so
the other
big considerations are timeliness
right so we need to
uh produce uh capacity plans on time
every month uh delays in in publishing
this plan can be costly
right so we um
we don't get new capacity unless it is
signaled in this plan
and if we don't get new capacity in a
timely manner
there's a risk of lost demand and other
delays so it's very important for us
that we produce plans
on time consistently
business strategy so we need to be agile
to incorporate new ideas thoughts uh
intelligence from our stakeholders and
leaders
so we need to override inputs in case
new information comes in or if there are
uh occasionally data quality issues with
some of our input data
so
if we do detect uh data quality issues
we need to be able to override and and
override those inputs in a non-hacky way
in a robust non-hacky way
and the last one i think in some ways um
in some ways this might be the most
important
consideration uh explainability
so we gain trust
only when we can explain the drivers
behind the capacity plan
in a clear and concise
manner
shiny apps help a lot with us by the way
so so we love
shiny apps we love shiny dashboards
uh i think it's only when
uh our explanations are
clear and concise
uh that
we are able to also be transparent with
our internal stakeholders and partners
so i really think explainability is is
one of these these key uh things that
you need that enables us to be
transparent
uh and when we are able to be
transparent and open with our partners
right about uh our model assumptions
about the input data that we see
then then we start building trust
right so being transparent
that enables us to build trust with our
stakeholders
and um you know that that trust uh it
leads to more questions right so
you know we
being able to build that trust uh leads
to us having good conversations with our
internal stakeholders
uh and that leads to more collaboration
right so i think i think this this
entire chain of goodness it starts from
being explainable right explainability
leads to transparency leads to trust
uh leads to collaboration uh so i think
i think this is a it's a big one for me
i'm very passionate about
uh explainability
okay so uh
with that said let me
uh talk about
uh how we use our studio connect
to
help us
address these considerations and help us
do our work
okay so
let me uh let me paint a picture of our
uh work life before
adopting uh our studio connect
um
so it's um
so truthfully it wasn't it wasn't bad it
wasn't bad at all uh it was not that
great either but it wasn't it wasn't
that bad uh
so so before using rstudio connect
models were developed by
data scientists using r and c sharp
and
the data scientists would check that
code in
and they would be deployed by engineers
in data pipelines using data bricks
it's important to note that most of our
data is mid-sized so we typically
deal with data that's you know at most
maybe 100
gigabytes roughly
right so our team doesn't really deal
with petabytes of data other other teams
deal with petabytes
we don't directly
deal with big data
and so
the the pipelines would run in data
bricks
it would take an hour for the pipeline
to run you would dump the data in some
database and then people would sort of
extract that
data
and
you know create static static tables
static graphs and paste them in
powerpoint presentations
and then they would present
these presentations with our
stakeholders
our stakeholders would
have feedback for us and then our data
scientists would have to either create
new models or modify existing models
and then the cycle would
uh continue
so
um
what are the what were the pain points
before we started using our studio
connect
um
i think i think the big one for me was
just slow
it was just slow slow slow um
slow end-to-end development time right
so that cycle that i just talked about
you know it's like a couple days uh
between when the data scientists would
you know modify some
uh you know model
uh to stakeholder feedback and and
remember we have to publish this this
capacity plan uh on a monthly basis
right there's there's 20 working days uh
in a month so three days is a long time
within that 20-day
uh time span
um
so data bricks is uh great for big data
right so data bricks and also
azure synapse these are these are
actually really great uh platforms for
dealing with big data from getting
insights
from big data but but for our case where
we're only working with a couple hundred
gigabytes of data it's actually a lot
faster for us to run
our models on the laptop or uh on a
desktop machine
right so it's uh really for our case uh
it should not take an hour for the
pipeline to to run and end
now having said that uh even in the
current workflow we still depend on big
data uh i think some of our upstream
teams they probably use some of these
big data platforms to produce our input
data so
um so i still think the other bricks is
great i think azure synapse is great but
for our
particular scenario it was um you know
we could get things done faster uh using
something else
uh hard to do what if scenarios so if
somebody wanted to change an input
parameter from one to two
uh you know yeah sure change the input
parameter of one to two
hit enter and then take an hour for the
results to to come out
so so that that that big lag between
changing an input and getting model
results you know that that makes it hard
to do other scenarios
and then uh visualization of results
so i will say that
uh you know during this time period
before we onboarded to rstudio connect
um our data scientists were already
experimenting with uh creating our shiny
apps
right
so we were already testing that out we
also were already sort of using it
internally in our team
uh but uh there was a big uh
requirement right there's a big desire
for us to be able to share those shiny
apps with our
internal partners and stakeholders right
so at that time we didn't have a means
of deploying shiny apps
and so
um
i think it was really really that need
uh to be able to deploy shiny apps uh
that uh prompted us to explore options
right and so i think the
the great option that we landed on was
um r studio connect
so
uh
okay so before i get to this slide a big
big shout out to ahmed gandhi who is no
longer with our team he's over in airbnb
i think he's i think he looked at this
situation before
and he was really instrumental uh really
really instrumental in driving our team
to adopt our studio connect
so so i think he's he's
i think he's a single person most
responsible for for sort of shifting our
team towards this this new model of
development
so uh after after we adopted our studio
connect what is the what is the model
for for how we work
uh in this new world data scientists own
the entire model development life cycle
so data scientists write
the data ingestion jobs they develop the
models
they deploy models on rstudio connect
and they write shiny apps
to visualize results
we also use some our markdown documents
as well
at the same time our engineers remain uh
vital indispensable
the engineers uh
we could not do our work without
engineers
they are responsible for
creating and maintaining the
infrastructure for running our studio
connect and other azure services
they are responsible for creating the
architecture
they they also help
shepherd
the r packages that data scientists
write right so there are questions about
uh you know data contracts how can we
ensure the data scientists work
seamlessly with each other but also with
other teams throughout microsoft so
engineers have a big part in that design
work
uh data compliance and security of
course big
big topics uh big areas of
responsibility
for the
engineers
advantages
so as i as i said before uh rstudio
connect empowers our data scientists to
directly communicate insights to
stakeholders they own the the
development life cycle and to end
uh the
end-to-end development time is now quick
right it can be as little as a couple
hours between
model development to deploying the app
on
our studio connect to getting
stakeholder feedback
uh easy collaboration between the data
scientists so we we love the pins
package by the way so we we share data
sets amongst ourselves using pins we
write um most of our code
in
our packages and we can share code
between ourselves by our packages uh
easily
and now it's easy to do what if
scenarios right so we
um we're able to
deploy plumber apis and we're able to
write shiny apps that talk to those
plumber apis
and so
in doing so we're able to create
dynamic apps right where people can
fiddle around with
input parameters and do sensitivity
analyses and
in essentially real time right so it
does not no longer takes an hour for
people to explore
um you know you know what happens if i
change this parameter or that parameter
it's now real time right due to this
combination of shiny apps
and
plumber apis
so
the return on investment
on our studio connect is
clear to us
so we have been consistently on time in
publishing the the capacity plan
every month
no delays
as i said before any delays are
they're potentially costly um so so
really being on time that's that's huge
uh transparency and explainability
uh so i'm a big fan of shiny apps shiny
dashboards
it's super quick to put together a
dashboard and deploy on our studio
connect
and even if some of the algorithms we
develop are black boxes
if people can can interact with the
models why are the shiny apps and if it
kind of looks right
then that that capability alone is is
powerful
all right so sometimes it's really hard
to sort of explain the the guts of an
algorithm
if it
on the other hand if it kind of looks
right if it performs as people expect it
you know in a lot of cases that alone
might might be sufficient right that
alone might go a long way towards
explainability and building that trust
that i talked about
um and finally i think our data
scientists are just happier i think
they're just they're just happier with
this uh with this new world
uh in terms of the uh data flow so let
me let me just touch upon this uh
briefly
uh describe sort of some how some of the
things we do to
ingest
data and also some of the
products that we we create using the
rstudio connect platform so so we do
run our studio connect on a linux d16 vm
we consume
data sources from our internal partners
via apis
cosmos db
data explorer which is also known as
cousto
and also some sql databases
uh we have a mechanism for incorporating
that human intelligence uh via
csv files that we store on azure blob
storage okay so it is a robust mechanism
that can use to override any
uh input data source as appropriate
uh our team
stores data using the pins package and
the azure store
r package right so we store our data on
azure blob storage
we deploy
plumber apis
and the plumber apis they
they power a number of downstream
applications as well
i love i love plumber api right it's
just super easy to just uh with a few
lines of code you can just go and deploy
the api
on rsd to connect
uh and uh yes and of course we spent a
lot of time developing shiny apps uh and
we do do some farm work down as well
uh and of course we use a whole bunch of
microsoft and azure services um so not
only do we plan
uh for azure data centers we are also
users of azure services ourselves
um
so a one one special shout out to to
excel by the way uh so
our team i mean we love our studio
connect we love dpplier and you know
tidy
but but we still remain big fans of
excel um so i think i've
um
so i i my philosophy on this and other
topics has has been
uh it's it's not a either or situation
it's it's an and situation right it's
like we don't have to pick between our
studio and excel we can do both right we
can we can use both
um both products uh successfully in our
process
and and by the way there are people who
um work almost entirely in excel but
they have a worksheet
where
they can pull the latest capacity plan
and they can they do that via the
plumber api
so that is a scenario that i've seen
some of our
uh internal customers use
okay so before i get to the demo itself
let me give a brief introduction to
availability zones so
availability zones are physically and
logically
separated data centers with their own
independent
power source
and
cooling
okay so
uh the basic idea is that if one of
these zones go down right uh perhaps due
to some natural disaster
or
um
you know
or maybe somebody accidentally hits the
power off switch
so if any of these things happen
then those workloads can can fill over
to to another availability zone and that
workload can continue to due to function
so it's this fill over capability that
gives
our customers workloads that the high
availability right it's
it's how we can guarantee these these
high slas for our customers
now in terms of uh demand we actually
think of a demand as split into three
buckets
so so there is a portion of demand that
we think of as being pinned
uh to a particular zone so
this workload must
uh happen in this physical location
right so there is that type of demand
uh there's a second class of demand
where
it's it's just you know it just has to
be replicated across all three zones
uh mainly for that resiliency that i was
talking about
and the the last type of demand is is
this
uh discretionary demand
so there's this third uh type of demand
where we are basically free to to
allocate that demand into
any
uh or all of these availability zones
as we see fit
okay so now
so we can we can place this demand we
can allocate this demand however we want
um and so then the question is well uh
how should we allocate this demand right
so there are a number of policies uh
that that we might want to um optimize
for right so
one might be we want to
allocate demand in such a way that
we try to maximize and equalize
the uh amount of excess supply that we
have in any of the three zones
right so that's that's perhaps one
policy objective
another policy objective might be
uh we want to push demand to uh zones
where we can get the most cost effective
supply
right so and there there could be others
as well right there are other heuristics
other policy
decisions uh or policies that
we might want to consider
when we're trying to allocate this this
discretionary demand
okay so
some some background on the demo that
you're about to see so
i had implemented a new algorithm for
distributing this discretionary demand
i spent hours debugging
uh the code
and debugging the code and
you know debugging the code um
and and you know at the end of that i
was finally able to create the first
version of the capacity plan
with this new
algorithm
and so i shared the results with our
program managers uh and and other
partners
and
um
the the feedback was was uh you know
there was there was some feedback that
said hey look this this doesn't look
right right this result doesn't look
right and so there are some genuine bugs
that were found and so i i went and
fixed those bugs
uh but there was other feedback that
that was like hey you know i
i'm not quite sure what the algorithm is
doing in this particular region
i would get questions like hey can you
actually explain what this algorithm is
actually doing i'm not i'm not quite
sure i understand right
and so it was it was uh
it was apparent to me after getting that
feedback that i really really needed
some type of visualization
uh to build trust in the algorithm that
i just developed right
to give people a sense of what the
algorithm was doing
without
uh actually having to delve too deep
into the details okay so
uh
so given that i spent a couple hours
putting together an interactive demo
uh that would allow people to adjust
some model parameters uh and to get a
feel for the algorithm right and so if
people can even just get a feel for the
the algorithm
um
then i think that would build trust and
competence in the algorithm even if i
don't delve too deeply into the the
nitty-gritty details
of the algorithm
okay so now let's uh let me uh let me
show the demo
of that um
of that tool that i just talked about
okay so
uh let's see
okay so the the tool that i was just
talking about uh it is um
it's i use a shiny dashboard to to build
this tool that tried to explain this
this new algorithm for allocating
discretionary demand
we are looking at supply and demand
graphs for a fictional region here right
so this is um
this is this particular region is a hala
so i know i know tom is a big fan of uh
captain marvel
and
i'm sure that microsoft would want to
build data centers on holla if it could
uh but anyways on the on the top
uh we see uh regional
uh supply demand right so this is this
is supply and demand that's
aggregated
on the region level
uh the black line here is
uh demand
and on the bottom here you see
the demand and supply distributed
amongst the three availability zones so
az1 ac2 az3
and you're also looking at the base case
scenario uh here
we also have info boxes right
at the bottom
so there's this uh risk index the supply
risk index
that is uh
color coded to be either green yellow or
red
as well as a demand forecast value
for the end of fiscal year 2024.
okay and so on the on the left side here
uh and the right side there are sliders
that allow users to adjust model
parameters
the left
sliders allow users to vary the safety
stock that we hold in each availability
zone
the right sliders they limit the maximum
amount of discretionary demand
that we can allocate to a particular
availability zone
and before i start playing around with
the input parameters i want to stress
again that all computations are live so
as i
you know vary the sliders uh calls are
being made to a plumber api
uh in the back end
and the model is actually recomputing
uh the results you see
right so for instance
uh i might want to
uh increase the
safety stock in in az2 right so
if i do that
then you see that there's this new dash
line that pops up
this corresponds to the what-if scenario
and you can see
the effect of changing this input
parameter
on output results
i can also for instance if i limit the
discretionary demand that goes to az1
okay so if i limit the the demand going
to ac1 you see that the the demand line
in az1 goes down but of course that
demand should be redistributed to other
az's as well
so so it's it was through this tool
that people got a sense of what the what
the algorithm was doing
uh and so yeah it seems to be doing the
right thing right even though
i didn't exactly explain the
nitty-gritty details uh of the algorithm
uh one more minor success story
associated with this tool so i switched
to the
grand city of uh
venus tirith here
uh so so here's another example that is
um somewhat similar to a real world case
uh so uh
the program manager
came to me and he was looking at results
looking similar to this
and and uh he was concerned about this
supply gap in az2
right so it was
and also yes the algorithm is doing its
thing it's distributing demand
uh but still you know there's this
little gap here right maybe the
algorithm isn't doing the right thing
so at that time it was it was really too
late in the in the uh publication
process for me to make any changes to
the code um so i wasn't gonna
make any changes to the algorithm at
this point so what we did instead was
hey you know let's can we can we try to
adjust the input parameters a little bit
uh to
see if we can make things better right
so it was through this interactive tool
where we played around with parameters
that we eventually settled on a solution
that looked like this where we said hey
what if what if we just
limit the amount of discretionary demand
that goes to az2
and so you see that when we did that all
of a sudden the supply risk index turns
green
it turns green in this case
um so so that was that was a
you know it was a minor success story
but
you know i felt very happy about that
right uh not only was was this uh tool
able to inform
uh give people a sense of what the
algorithm was uh doing
uh but we even we haven't used it to do
a little uh planning right we even used
it to
actually implement the change in the
input parameter and that became part of
our official plan of record
uh another tool
uh that
uh that we built
uh it's this uh
you know
long-range capacity plan uh compare
uh so we built this tool to compare the
month-over-month changes between
different versions of the capacity plan
right so for this synthetic data set
we have a capacity plan for december
2021
and an updated plan for january 2022
so you know people
can click execute get results so i click
again
so again it's it's talking to a plumber
api in the background
and so
uh yeah with uh so this this table by
the way is a reactable table
um
and so people can quickly see that hey
you know on the regional level
the the latest capacity plan is uh
asking for you know 30.5 units of data
center in june 2082
that goes up to about 60 in june 2025
and you can see that the deltas right
the month over month changes uh
between the latest uh version of the
capacity plan versus the previous months
and and people can also drill down a
little bit too right like hey what are
the are the contributing factors to this
regional uh forecast right the organic
component the networking component the
engineering component
um now the real version of this this
uh tool it actually has a lot more
tables and and features i had to i just
trip out most of the features for for
this presentation
okay but you know for instance people
can also click on the engineering table
right and hey you know what are the
components of these engineering capacity
asks right so you can see hey
different uh engineering groups have
have different capacity uh requests
okay so that's uh that i think that does
it for the
demo let me
let me end this off
with
two more slides so
um
[Music]
okay
here's a you know suggestion right so if
you are interested in trying out rstudio
connect on azure
how would you go about doing that well i
i recommend uh people uh create an azure
account if they have not already done so
um
you know i personally love it i love
azure i love using azure products um so
it's i if i remember correctly i think
there are some trial credits that people
can can get to sort of try try it out
highly recommend azure services
um
for for the purposes of trying out our
studio connect on azure right you can
provision a linux uh virtual machine we
ourselves settled on ubuntu 18. um i
think you can also use ubuntu 20.
install a trial version of our studio
connect on that vm
uh if if your organization is adopting
one of these hybrid cloud strategies
you might also consider
provisioning an express route
instance so express route
allows for secure communications between
your cloud vm running rstudio connect
and your on
on-prem network
and
and finally we do use azure active
directory for
user authentication in
uh our studio connect
okay so and then finally i'm just uh i
just want to really really thank our
fantastic uh internal partners at
microsoft and our program manager
teammates our teammates and finance and
supply
we just have a fantastic team i'm
i'm a very very happy person here uh at
microsoft uh and and special thank you
to uh rachel tom and mitch uh for
helping us on board to our studio
connect um so tremendously helpful in
guiding us through the process um
giving us tips on uh you know how to how
to deploy shiny um tremendously
tremendously helpful
uh and so with that i will toss it back
to you rachel
awesome thank you so much paul
it's really amazing to see
how you showed that it can be one hour
from model development to stakeholder
feedback in that example
i know there's a lot of questions coming
in
and depending on where you're watching
from if you're on linkedin when you
comment there the questions will get to
us as well or you can put comments into
slido or the youtube chat as well
and tom is in the background helping me
with that
but i see um paul neil had asked a
question
that was how are you measuring accuracy
oh that's a that's a big uh topic um one
of our program managers is passionate
he's passionate about accuracy
um i will say that uh our team has
actually been at this for
um almost five years now
so so we are we are in a relatively rare
position where we did some forecasting
you know back in 2017 and we're actually
able to see whether those predictions of
handheld in the year 2021 and 2022. so i
think i don't i don't think anything
beats actual real world
um real world confirmation
great thank you
hey monica i see you had asked a
question on youtube as well
um
can you give an example paul of what a
shiny dashboard with explainable metrics
would look like
um so uh so we we actually did create
another tool
um that gave um some summary statistics
of you know our data center capacity
plans so these are i mean a lot of these
metrics these are metrics are familiar
to um
our internal stakeholders right so
you know we don't
you know they actually have metrics that
they are comfortable with and so we
actually try to create metrics that talk
to them
we loved the shiny dashboard i'm
actually a big fan of shiny dashboard so
you know those boxes um
i think that was that was great
cool thank you paul i'm going to read
over a question from slido as well so
you can ask anonymous questions there
too
one of the questions was
are multiple models used for the various
forecasts
or is a single most accurate model
chosen for each variable
um
so we
we do have
um
we do
we have considered
multiple models
um i think i think my description of
uh how we're doing the demand
forecasting right this this model of
technology
uh diffusion inspired by diego komen um
coupled with this hierarchical
time series um
[Music]
model i think that's that is what we're
uh using
uh right now i mean if the question is
about like do we do like you know random
forests or some sort of ensemble
uh i our team
currently doesn't um
we don't currently use that
uh but i do know that there is we do
have a partner team that does exactly
that that uses an ensemble approach
thanks paul i'm just going to keep
throwing questions at you because
there's a lot of great ones here um one
was
was forecast modeling a data analyst
driven initiative or was this primarily
through management
oh uh
hey gee that's that's a good question um
i
i think in some sense it's it's a bit of
both right um i mean there's a lot of
history to that i mean certainly within
microsoft microsoft understands the the
value of data science and and
um you know analyzing data right so
microsoft has many many other
initiatives right um
you know involving ai and vision and so
forth so microsoft's already bought into
um this idea of hey you developing
forecasts using data science um
at the same time though uh there is a
little bit of a bottoms up feel to this
as well i mean i think i think our data
scientists are
uh tremendously empowered to actually
come up with uh their own ideas
right it's like hey you know i think i
think we have a better uh forecast or
maybe we can do things differently so i
think we
on our team we really empower our data
scientists to to sort of
drive other initiatives
beyond what management tells us to do
that's great i am going back over to
some of the questions from linkedin too
we're all we're jumping all over the
place here but um heath had asked i saw
that power bi was utilized as well um
were there any reasons why you ported
this over to shiny or was it just more
convenient to use connect as a platform
so i i will
so before i answer that i will say that
we still use power bi dashboards as well
right so i i think i said this before my
philosophy isn't necessarily an either
or uh situation right so it's it's many
uh uh you know many tools so so we do
have a fantastic uh um
power bi platform as well um and then we
do use rbi uh by having said that i
think our data scientists their most
proficient and are
and so it's just it's just easier to to
code up uh shiny apps um it's it's a
familiar language it's r based lots of
great packages uh and you can test test
it very quickly on your own desktop
machine before deploying it to our
studio um so at least for our team
uh it is way more convenient to use rc
to connect and to deploy shiny apps but
at the same time there is uh there's a
definite role for power bi as well
definitely
a lot of other anonymous questions
coming in too and one was when
publicizing forecasting and planning how
is feedback managed
are analysts given leeway to consider
model feedback or is it more centrally
managed
i think it's uh there's there's a mix
there right so there's not it's not like
there's a there's a central team that
takes all the feedback and then tells us
what to do it's not like that at all
um analysts are definitely given uh
leeway
we definitely have a lot of a lot of
control uh over sort of what the things
we do um we are still very uh time
constrained by the way so we're actually
quite busy we can't do at all so we do
have to be a little bit um
selective in some cases right it's like
hey let's go after the the big ticket
items the the
high priority items
the other the other aspect to this is
that
alongside
um i actually didn't mention this but
alongside our um
our use of our studio connect we also
developed a
business process that goes along with
that right so as i said before right i
really like this this idea where
explainability leads to transparency
leads to
you know collaboration i really i really
think that that is true and so in our
case
that that really did happen we actually
did
uh get a lot more collaboration from
from our partners so
every month we have these forums
right with with multiple
uh
partners where our entire team
of program managers data scientists we
sit in the forum alongside our
uh our stakeholders and it's in that
entire forum that we consider hey here's
the latest plan
you know what's the latest changes what
are the input drivers
uh so it's all it's all very open we
have these
fantastic forms where we're you know
getting feedback and and collaborating
sometimes in real time so it's just it's
just really great
i love that i i'd love to learn more
about that too
do you
how did you start those forums
uh
i think i think it's uh i think it's
mainly about organic process i guess uh
so i mean i mean as i said the world
before we did have you know
presentations to to partners and stuff i
think it's
um
at this point in time those are uh those
are much more um
you know the scheduling is much more
expected right so we have we have a we
have a monthly process and we have we
have you know dates
uh when certain forums happen when
certain
uh deliverables uh happen uh so it's i
get i think it's probably
from my perspective i think that that
kind of grew
uh organically i guess
nice
i see a great question on youtube that
came in from darren and i'm really
curious about this too what is your
biggest future feature request for
rstudio connect or the packages that
you're using
oh man
[Laughter]
so like like any any uh again love rc to
connect uh i do
um so i myself so i do use rcu to
connect heavily but uh i also use a
sequel in c sharp and visual studio
heavily as well so uh and so i think i
think some of the
uh some of the debugging uh features in
visual studio um i think i think it's
easier to to debug code in visual studio
than it is in our studio so um
it's uh it's feedback uh i think you
know i would be i would be very happy if
if
there were future
improvements our studio to sort of make
the debugging experience a little bit
more like a visual studio
to the rstudio team listening we'll
write that one down
[Laughter]
um going back to i know that question
about power bi and our studio connect i
see thomas
had a comment as well that said great
presentation
we have embedded power bi dashboards
within our shiny apps and use azure
functions for some plumber apis
um
is that an architecture you consider too
uh i didn't even know that was possible
i have to try that out so you take the
you take the power bi and you certain
embed it in the shiny
app wow i've got the um
thomas i think that's a great
presentation too we'd love to see that
yeah
i see there's um let's see some other
questions from
linkedin paolo asked
what's the main reason to use a rest api
when re-running the model
uh i think so so from a
engineering perspective you want to
decouple the um the graphical user
interface from the underlying
model and code so apis they really
provide a
you know language language independent
way of of sort of
decoupling
back-end code from from gui so that's
that's i think that's that's very good
um
that's very good design
thanks paul
one of the anonymous questions
that came through is who are the users
of your platform
like teams and titles for example and
how many concurrent users can your app
handle at one time
uh so at this point to be honest we are
still running on one
linux vm
so uh it is highly available but it is
just one linux vm we we should uh expand
that out so use azure skill sets to to
sort of have multiple vms um
i think i think our license right now
it's um
it's a couple hundred users right so i
think i think we can handle a couple you
100 users
maximum at this point but yeah to really
scale out uh we need to
sort of uh stand up more linux vms and
have that
use an average skill set
thanks paul i realized an hour went by
really quickly and just want to double
check that you have a few more minutes
to ask answer a few other questions okay
great
um i see heath that said i'm impressed
that you train and deploy models in
hours rather than days
um what is the pipeline that you're
using for modeling is that tidy models
uh so i will
okay so
training and deploying so i think
um
so there are there are certain
ways of running your data pipeline where
you do the majority of training sort of
in the at the front um of the process if
that makes sense right so i mean think
of
uh
so what is that again uh think of uh
transfer learning
right so in the transfer learning
scenario the the models are almost uh
already pre-trained and you're simply
sort of replacing the last layers of
that model to sort of adapt that model
to whatever situation you're you're uh
looking at now our situation is not
quite uh like that um
uh but it is it is true that and as i
said we're not working with petabytes of
data either we are working with hundreds
of gigabytes of data so that makes a
that's another reason why it's faster
for us to
run the models on our local machines
right um
if anything takes days uh we're we're
back to uh azure synapse right
then we're not we're not running these
things on our local machines anymore
thanks paul
um someone asked are you all using
linear programming to do these zone
modeling functions um for the
discretionary demand piece
uh the short answer is no um i i
actually think that in my
so i've actually worked on a couple
other projects where you know
these these types of constraints
satisfaction problems where
you know you're trying to allocate
demand or allocate uh you know number of
seats or whatever and some
problem um i've actually to be honest
with you i've actually never used linear
programming
in practice myself
i've often used uh these types of
traditional ai techniques to try to do
the optimization
in this particular case it's actually
simpler than that we just it was just a
bunch of heuristics that we employed in
the algorithm
and so i'm pretty sure that the
heuristics that we employed are not
necessarily optimal
um
there is there is a case to be made to
sort of balance between optimality and
explainability by the way right so if
you if you try to optimize your
algorithm too much you have a you in
general you might have a harder time
explaining yeah so so if your answer is
no we don't use linear programming
thanks paul
there was another question about the
dashboard itself so for external and
internal users of the dashboard is there
a need to consider other layouts to
accommodate needs of different
stakeholders oh that's an awesome
question uh so we do have a bunch of uh
tented projects within microsoft right
so these are these are projects where
only certain
people within microsoft should have
access to that information um so
so in that case we actually uh came up
with a
simple solution right so we do have
access to other uh databases within
microsoft that says that hey this set of
users have access to this information
right and so
and so we basically put in if switches
in the shiny app right that says if the
user is in this group then go ahead and
enable this conditional panel
to to sort of show that data
yeah that's that's a great question
thank you
one other question that came on
youtube jumping over there was from
robert
that asked how do you tackle
troubleshooting the application itself
on azure when problems come up
uh
troubleshooting on azure itself
so i i have to be honest um
and
this is this is truth
here uh we haven't had much problems
with azure itself um so i think our
our main uh focus when we did have to
debug was actually you know our logic
right so our our code our shiny apps
uh you know sometimes our c sharp code
um so it's we've you know a lot of the
debugging and troubleshooting is on that
front our azure services have been
um the services we use they've actually
have been pretty stable highly available
so i
we haven't had the opportunity of the
necessity to have to troubleshoot
thanks fall one other question about
azure on slido someone said the azure vm
sizing seems quite huge is that for our
studio connect or our processes only or
are there other processes running on the
vm
so we uh
so our linux vm is totally dedicated uh
to running the rstudio uh connect um so
yes it is this is a little big
uh yes um there are
some models um
right because we're not running on a
distributed computing system right so we
have to
some some models we do
need some extra cpu power
so
um
yeah
thank you so much paul i think i've gone
through
almost all of the questions let me see
if others are chatting in there on
youtube or linkedin
one question that i had for you was
around communicating with different
stakeholders across the business and
once you made that application how do
you actually get people
to use it
yeah and any tips that you have for us
all oh so there there was a time when we
first created the shiny app where um
ahmed gandhi uh basically assigned uh
all the data scientists to go on a um
go go on a selling spree
so he actually said hey you know uh you
know uh you know
jingyi go go talk to this group and i'll
go talk to that group uh so there was uh
initially there was a bit of uh
uh you know process we actually had to
go on a you know
selling spree right a real chill um so i
think that was good i think that
actually
you know it's uh i'm not i'm not sure if
that's necessarily within
our comfort zone so force us to do
something new
um it is important to sort of advertise
right so if you if you build it and you
don't advertise nobody's going to come
um but at the same time though as i said
before we did have a you know there was
a world before our studio connect so we
already had stakeholders and and
partners so
from that perspective it was just easy
right it's like hey we built this app
please check it out and you know demo it
during one of these presentations right
now but it was it was important right
because we started you know showing
these shiny apps and as i said before
right hey that was explainable well now
it's
now now you're getting more transparent
you're you're you know showing us all
the
all the assumptions and stuff so
yeah why did you go on a bit of a sales
sales mission there
that's great i love that going on the
selling spree for the app
um i see there's one other question or
sorry two other questions left um and
one was how often do microsoft teams use
python and its web frameworks compared
to our studio and shiny dashboards
so
uh
to be honest with you i'm not exactly
sure about the
um
i'm not exactly sure about the
percentage um
i i do know that there are a lot of
users uh of python throughout uh
microsoft uh i do know that there are
actually also um
you know some teams within uh microsoft
that uses uh r right like our team and i
know there's there's a couple other
teams out there as well uh in terms of
actual percentage i i won't hazard a
guess
but i will say that um
you know rstudio connect
as i understand it uh you know you're
you're able to deploy both python and nr
uh and you can you know access python
via reticulate right so i think so in
some sense
uh you know it's again it's not one of
these either or situations we can use
both python and r
even though our team hasn't
used python uh yet uh that doesn't
necessarily mean that we won't in the
future we might there might be some
things that you know python is more
appropriate for
right i was looking for a link to share
in the chat but i can't do two things at
once right now but yes you could share
like flask dash or streamlet for example
to r studio connect as well
let me just double check on any other
questions that the one last question was
for the plumber apis is that only
running r code or
do they call
c-sharp or any other
oh that's also a great question so uh
there is um
a lot of the plumber apis uh they are
running r code
but we do have our packages that call
into
a
[Music]
a web server that's running on c sharp
um so so again it's not one of these
there's not a it's not either or a
situation um so
uh there is there is some functionality
that we needed that could not be done in
r so we use c sharp for that uh and we
made sure that the r code connected with
the c sharp code
but from the perspective our data
scientists it's seamless right they they
may not even realize that that's c sharp
code in the end uh you know from their
perspective it's just our package making
uh
you know making calls
thank you so much paul for staying on
with us and i know i said last question
before but i really mean it this is sure
too
um i see
in the chat someone just asked how do
you maintain the reproducibility of the
application
is there any containerization process
uh
is that so is that referring to
reproducibility of the results itself
um
like are plans reproducible
i think it might be
about deploying the application and
let's see feel free to jump in oh
i mean the application itself i mean
that's that's pretty reproducible right
it's um you know we use git so we we
check in code
we have we have uh
an azure devops pipeline that that sort
of deploys
some of these shiny apps and plumber
apis to
the
rstudio connect so that part is
reproducible the um the more interesting
question perhaps is reproducibility of
our results and so
again i showed that lrp compare app
right comparing different versions of a
capacity plan and trying to understand
the
different input drivers right what's
changed between last month and this
month
um so i think that that itself um
it makes it
it makes it very reproducible
it's um i think i think we just um not
not to say that we take it for granted i
mean work needs to be done to ensure
that our results are consistent
reproducible robust there aren't any
books um so there is a there's a lot of
work that needs to be done to make sure
uh that we eliminate bugs and when you
eliminate bugs you are reproducible in
our case
definitely well thank you so much paul
for answering all the questions here and
it's great to see how many people have
had questions on linkedin and youtube
and on twitter
so i'd say this was a great
youtube live experiment for us here
but thank you so much paul for amazing
presentation i really appreciate your
time and and sharing your experience
with us here
oh that's awesome and thank thanks so
much rachel and tom and everybody our
studio for uh hosting us uh we really
appreciate it i know you shared quite a
few links at the end of your slides on
like getting started with azure for
example
so i'll be sure to share the slides with
the youtube recording
but i can take out some of those helpful
links too
awesome
awesome well thank you all for joining
and thank you so much paul have a great
rest of the day everyone great thank you
bye